[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
super excited to be talking about
evidence-based drug policy we have dr.
Luis Amer joining us on the show hello
hi Ellen thanks for inviting me thank
you so much for coming on the show
really appreciate it
very excited this is gonna be an epic
episode we have yet to really dive deep
into this subject specifically for those
that don't know Larissa's background
she's a Swiss psychologist and postdoc
research fellow at the University of
California San Francisco funded by the
Swiss National Science Foundation prior
to this she was appointed as a
consultant in drug use epidemiology at
the United Nations Office on Drugs and
Crime she received her PhD in psychology
at the University of Zurich in
Switzerland and is a member of the core
research team of global drug survey
aiming to make drug use safer regardless
of the legal status of the drug and you
can find the links in the bio to her
profile UCSF as well as her LinkedIn and
Twitter and the global drug survey comm
website alright listen let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world well as we all know the world is
changing and what I hope for is of
course any positive change so I see a
lot of positive changes happening like
people coming together sitting together
at a table and talking getting into
dialogue communicating but at the same
time there are still lots of
inequalities that have to be addressed
and I strongly believe that we can do
that together and that we need more
science to actually also help people
understand what ways are functional to
actually address inequalities in a
beneficial way what ways do you think
science can best address the
inequalities well first of all it's to
help them detect them and also help
detect which system level variables
actually increase such existent
inequalities and
next step think about like how we can
best prevent this also when we look at
current discussions around AI and the
inclusive future of AI this becomes very
important you know you know science can
help us save the world this is so is so
true
only if it gets hurt if it gets hurt
yeah hurt heard only if people listen oh
if it gets hurt yeah yeah yeah that's
right yes yeah science it definitely
needs to be heard yes yes
yeah and that's so hopefully the
dissemination of good media content can
help as well get it better heard yeah
who were you growing up and how did you
get interested in psychology teachers
about you well when I was a small girl I
was always like curious about the world
and I asked my parents a lot of
questions so already then I wanted to
understand the world not just why the
sky is blue but also especially I was
interested in in like enter human
relationships and how people engage with
each other how people made each other
happy or angry or like all the different
kinds of emotions and very early on I
also learned how it feels like to be
rejected by a group when I was like
skipping a class and was suddenly with
the older ones it was really hard to
become part of that group and moving on
I was seeing that substance use was
actually community building and not
destroying communities so this helped me
understand why certain people who'd use
drugs to actually belong to a certain
group that they admired so that was like
the very beginning of my like substance
use research career if you want so but
the overall interest in science and
explaining things that matter to us was
always there yeah that the sense of
belonging that's you that sometimes
missing especially in some of our issues
with the current social fabric that
we're in that that the it's missing that
link of like the family values and the
belonging and the inclusive fitness
these types of things so sometimes the
use of drugs is like frequently about
belonging
well it depends figures again like the
majority of people who use legal or
illegal drugs they use them probably for
social reasons or reasons of self
medications so we can almost say that
all the kind of drug use is related to
connectedness and if not connection to
one another then maybe connection to the
universe yeah yeah okay okay so okay so
substance use can be for a lack of
connection interconnectedness to each
other may be trauma that's happened
earlier in life and also the pursuit of
connection to the to the universe
there's so much nuance here to unpack
okay so what was what was it like when
you were doing the work the PhD work at
the University of Zurich in psychology
what was that time like yeah for you
teachers about that well it was really
funny because when I ended my master and
submitted my master thesis I was not
really sure what to do next so I was
excited to travel where whereas other
people were like actively seeking post
PhD positions and I didn't even know
what it's all about like for me research
at a time I was only interested in the
results I was not interested like how
these results were like actually like
developed and what the study design
behind the studies were because I was
just learning about what science taught
me so I was further away from the
research process than other people
nowadays I'm very carefully and closely
looking at how the science is produced
and at the time when I was a master
student my master thesis was on party
drug prevention in the city of Zurich
where we actually implemented a
questionnaire that was then used
together with the drug checking services
like that's a facility where people can
test their drugs that we actually
learned something about the substance
use behavior of these people and for my
PhD it went even further so there we
look specifically at people who were
using substances not just for
recreational reasons but for reasons of
enhancement to actually enhance their
academic performance or their
performance at work so that was really
interesting and at the time the first of
the studies conducted in Switzerland so
we started off
student populations at the university of
zurich ath and university of basel of
the 6,000 people sample and even
increased it to a 10,000 people national
representative sample to look at the
whole population that was actively
engaged so these numbers they were much
lower than then predicted but still like
interesting numbers to look at were my
first publications and my first steps in
the actual science I can better now
understand how you became who you are
from all that work that you like laid a
foundation of all your understanding of
things and then in 2017 consulted with
the UN's Office on Drugs and Crime
through a drug use of ideologies so what
was that like well that was a really
interesting position like if we have
already did first let's show the first
one now the career path in science I'll
show that one exactly if we already see
the career path in science then you
actually I want to point out that it
looks pretty perfect but it went from
working at the Swiss research institute
for public health actually graduating
with my PhD to being short term
unemployed yeah because that also
happened because I tried to get the
scholarship to come to San Francisco and
everyone believed that I would get that
but it didn't happen
so I field for the first time and by
being unemployed the European Monitoring
Centre of drug drug use and addiction
drug addiction they recommended me to
apply for a consultancy at the united
nations office on drugs and crime and
that consultancy was specifically
looking at substance use among school
students in afghanistan and neighboring
countries so that even widened my
horizon by the time i was working with
the cold with drug story because i did
an internship in 2014 so I had a pretty
broad perspective on substance use
across countries already but of course
in Afghanistan neighboring countries
there is not so much social media use
there is of course a different political
system where people also don't feel as
comfortable to take a survey online
about drugs even if they have access to
these things so they are the whole thing
about being punished for using drugs no
matter whether by the parents or by the
system is of course higher whereas
people in the Western world feel more
comfortable
and actually keen to share their
experiences to help other people who may
struggle with drug use even that nugget
there is critical for us in the west of
realize how much more comfortable we
have the privilege of vocalizing or our
drug use versus ones that cannot was a
majority of work with the UN was a
researcher for Afghanistan yes exactly
we were providing technical assistance
for the countries and that was a very
interesting like process also to learn
how divert in the field and what
challenges they face with different
ministries who seem to be responsible
and involved in that truck survey so
that was a huge thing because other than
with the global drug survey where we
basically asked what is relevant what is
important for the people who use trucks
and so on there it's really much guided
by the ministries what can be asked and
what can't be asked because they don't
want to encourage drug use by asking
questions and of course there are
different terminologies of different
drugs and so on and then so then how did
it move to UCSF from there well while
being a consultant I actually applied
for a second time at the Swiss National
Science Foundation for this early career
postdoc mobility grant and in a second
time I was actually successful and that
provided me to move to your opportunity
to actually move to San Francisco and
start my postdoc in April 2018 by the
time I moved I already got involved in
many different professional societies
that was also part of my career
development at this stage where I was
unemployed where I was looking for new
challenges and so on so I was really
backed up by the european society for
Prevention's research with which is kind
of like the small sister from the
Society for prevention research that
actually had the conference here in San
Francisco last week so you've got
immersed immediately until the different
kind of societies out here that could
help boost the career faster and
connections faster and research faster
okay and now when it's been almost a
year and a half
approaching a year and a half now the
ucsf with doing the postdoc research so
we actually have a bunch of good slice
to start unpacking with this let's jump
into the tobacco cannabis control and
impact on youth yeah okay so u.s.
cannabis laws in 2019 yeah this is
actually like the graph from governing
dot-com and if you can see this one
Illinois's the the graph online was lost
updated May 22nd and lost Friday there
was a cannabis the recreational use of
cannabis was legalized in Illinois so
I've added this light green for a
different shape but my graphical skills
are so it's actually by now eleven
states that have like legalized cannabis
for recreational use at the age of
twenty-one and one of the research
questions I'm looking at I'm interested
in is whether anything has changed with
regard to the use of cannabis among
youth like those people who are not
eligible to buy from the legal market
but still that that is the group that
I'm most interested in because there was
enough information and a delay of onset
of regular cannabis use and you can
really be beneficial for those people
who decide to use cannabis early on and
for that I'm comparing different data
sources from the National Household
surveys also the global drug survey data
set that I have and I'm not interested
in just a prevalence of drug use I'm not
interested in how many have tried ever
or in the last year because if that just
was once or twice
that's probably probably a relatively
low risk and not very concerning but I
want to see whether there were changes
at the like amount of views or frequency
of use or a change in different cannabis
products because of course here in the
US you have a really broad palette of
different cannabis products that are
available of different kinds of
potencies and especially young people
are very vulnerable
like for risks related to this truck so
within the eleven states that have
legalized recreational use for those
that are over 21 you were analyzing to
see if their habits changed with the
legalization in their state exactly I
use it more and especially for those
young people who are anyway not affected
by the legal changes because if we
discuss the cannabis law or the legal
law it kind of is far away from the
reality that the first experiences that
people make with cannabis use are
usually at the age of 12 to 21 so minors
are yeah so the like for them that they
still have to go to the black market or
ask someone to buy for them in the legal
market but however like what we need to
see is with the current markets existing
on the Internet including the clear net
but also the dark net it's more it's
easier than ever especially for Western
societies to buy cannabis and when we
were young like also our parents had
access to cannabis and you and I we had
both access when we were young but maybe
you needed to know at least one of the
cool persons in a certain group right
and this is not the case anymore today
so we have to discuss like education
about drugs very differently because the
access has increased everywhere and this
is nothing we can currently stop after
different forms of regulation and in the
findings were that the frequency
increase or decrease or the findings are
still analyzing so I'm looking at
different data sets but overall it
doesn't seem that the cannabis markets
have actually changed use paver among
youth and the most important predictor
for actually predicting cannabis use
among youth like under the age of 21 is
always appear drug use like whether
their peers is using or not okay yeah
okay okay and then then also that that
was that also with the tobacco control
was that also with the tobacco control
as well who's the tobacco control and
we're sitting in San Francisco we have
among
most restrictive laws for like tobacco
control and they had have huge successes
in also banning cigarette use among
youth and another form of use has has
come up like the e-cigarettes that we
see so that's a whole different area
that we want touch big-time today but
it's also worth noting that for like
adults who are using cigarettes
e-cigarettes can be a wonderful way of
reducing harm especially when they use
occasionally like everything that is not
burned is actually better but then again
like of course it's more attractive to
young people and it's also available
although for example companies like you
will have great systems to like look
whether the H is where the people are
old enough to buy these these items but
still of course young people who want to
have access to it they still have what
are some of the restriction laws that
San Francisco has on tobacco well one of
specific ones is that they actually
banned the sales of flavored tobacco so
in the shops you can no longer buy
menthol cigarettes or like vapes
like nicotine containing flavors as that
that was one of the laws and now they're
trying there's another public hearing
coming up this Friday where they really
try to get rid of all the e-cigarette or
wave devices to be sold in California in
San Francisco yeah Australia has some
crazy packaging on their cigarettes that
makes it right yeah like you will die
smoking these like get cancer and like
it prevents more people from from
purchasing it and the whole movement
would do ecig these cigarettes and
joules and stuff that that would be
another interesting feel to see what
happens with the evidence based drug
policy in the future cuz getting young
kids addicted to nicotine when they're
like sixteen is a whole under-researched
area of and what that actually happens
with brain and physiology in general
um yeah and so then um what was it that
this this image here you had was you
have you have a story about this that is
actually really profound go ahead and
yet teach us about this yeah maybe to
make the link between tobacco and
cannabis what is interesting what we see
in the global drug surveys that people
who use cannabis like in Europe or like
I think it's Italy was the highest like
countries respondents that were
answering to the survey really at
tobacco when they smoke cannabis whereas
here in America usually almost no one
like 9 over 90% use justa cannabis like
they also have like the wave devices
where they can use the pure cannabis but
when people smoke cannabis in in form of
a joint at least in Europe and in many
other countries people add tobacco which
is not the case here so that's very good
for the health of people who use
cannabis but then the industry of course
has also gotten more more innovative and
creative to actually think about those
people who maybe not want to smoke or
like combust cannabis at all but maybe
still want to get that high and so there
has a whole has been a whole new
industry around edible use and edible is
like food that contains cannabis and we
also need to define there is canopy's
with THC and CBD content and the THC is
the component and other components that
are actually making its like active
whereas the CBD the canopy beta all can
also be used just for relaxation
purposes and so when we look for example
at the Swiss law or certain European
laws we see that cannabis with less than
1% THC which is not psychoactive is
legal so like all the CBD products can
also be sold as cakes or as tea or as
even as like liquids as that doesn't
matter and you can still drive a car to
whu-oh the World Health Organization has
also confirmed that but on the other
hand with
we see in the United States increasing
potency increased potency of cannabis or
THC in certain food products and this
one the example that I'm showing here is
a recent example in Amsterdam when I was
there to speak at a club health
conference that was a really nice
conference about nightlife and drug use
and how it all interacts and how to
include the different stakeholders and
there the conference ended on the day
May 17th was my 30th birthday so all my
friends from Switzerland would come over
to celebrate my birthday during that
weekend and on Saturday the following
day there was a date/time festival in
Amsterdam and so I actually choked and
said like very Amsterdam the trucks are
pretty good like that's another story I
will come back to later but I don't mind
if you take drugs but please don't do
space cakes because space cakes no
matter how much cannabis or THC is in
there they're really unpredictable with
their effects so it takes a lot of time
delayed reaction time up to 1.5 hours is
here and it remains long so state our
facts as well yeah and do we know about
how many milligrams of cannabis go into
a space cake well that depends on the
factory that's just one of the Michelin
star guided that my girls found and they
were like oh this is of course a good
brand it looks nice that's like a
passion fruit cake and it has a good
description and on the other side it's
also clear that our pleasure is your
pleasure so they really care for their
customers and clients so everything you
can know including the THC content was
was there and they were also aware of
what you do but on the other hand when
they walked out actually thinking about
dosing responsibly someone else told
them here in Amsterdam go hard or go
home so what they did is they went hard
they three girls ate both of these cakes
but they made it to the festival and
then also went home because it was
obviously too much and different things
like high potency cannabis used orally
can also lead
to psychiatric symptoms or you can have
anxiety and the only good thing is it's
all in your brain it's just happening in
your brain like no one else from
cannabis but still it can be really
overwhelming for someone who didn't have
an experience like this before
yeah the the pressure first the the the
what we're manufacturing and then also
the the pressure that comes from others
on go hard or go home culture and and
you can ruin a full a person's full day
of life like we you only get so many
days twenty thousand days to live and if
we accidentally waste one we feel like
and then you have to spend the next day
kind of recovering so you can waste like
two days of your life and that's a big
deal if we're not educated enough I've
done plenty of wasteful things like this
in my life
my bad behaviors my bad decisions of
these and to educate young people to be
like DOS appropriately is so so critical
and to thank goodness nobody got yea
hurt but they but they anxiety is real
as well there's so many components to
this so we when we think about the
industry what we would want to see is
also that they take more responsibility
that they may be not sent them out of
the cakes but maybe also create like a
safe space and the room where people can
have this experience it may be more
something like a chill out instead of
sending them back to the city and all
the tourist attractions or whatever they
do that yeah an hour and a half to or
delay the onset and then six to eight
hour like those are also major yeah
there's a major time like yeah and when
you're in Amsterdam the funny thing is
that also for example Silas's of
truffles and mushrooms are legal and
Alice E and other drugs but the fun
thing is they have a trip stopper so
they also give a trip stop never chip
stopper what are so no servants who
knows these trip stoppers I don't know I
I didn't read what's actually in there
but you can buy them also trip stopper
and drink it or something or eat it yes
exactly it's it's sold like a package
could be like any new psychoactive
substance from the internet but it sold
as a trip stopper and I have
heard of that before either but it
obviously helps you to calm down earlier
and I didn't know I wasn't aware of that
exists let's try and not make the
boo-boos the mistake in the first place
to need a trip stopper to yeah yeah
exactly it's not about it's for kind of
not about the cannabis as well yeah yeah
Wow Wow okay and then okay let's see on
the next slide Ronnie
okay so teach us about the THC CBD
content and edibles well that was a very
well informed sample actually took part
in a global drug survey 2019 data we
collected in November December 2018 so
very recently and this is something we
haven't published in the key findings
but the key findings are online and here
we looked at people from 16 countries
like a sample of 6000 people who have
used edibles and like these edibles so
they eat cannabis as part of their
cannabis use structure they also have
other forms of cannabis use most of them
but here we see that about like only 16%
are aware of both the CBD and THC
content something you want to know and
most of the sample came actually from
the United States and from Germany
because we had pretty big interest in
the United States and a pretty big
sampling in Germany and we see we've
seen an age difference so we've seen
that people who are 25 years and older
were more likely to be good informed
compared to the minors and that was also
due to those who can access a legal
market of course all those were a bit
older compared to the younger but the
younger ones also do it so again they're
those who don't have access to legal
markets like in Amsterdam or here in the
United States in several states they
actually bake it and make it make it
themselves at home so the very
old-fashioned way and that's the most
prevalent way of sourcing cannabis
edibles still so when you make it on
your own you may be may be able to know
the strength of your th the cannabis
that you buy but you never know how that
turns out and how its distributed in the
things you bake yeah did this the green
bar of awareness needs to
you rocketed upward we need to be aware
of what we are consuming all the time
all the time exactly in food in drug use
in all different aspects of our lives
even the algorithms that control our
technology just to be aware of they do
it yeah yeah and on alkyl bottles you
actually have like the indication on how
much the alkyl person is but on on all
the cannabis and other drugs that are
sold via the illegal market you have
actually no idea yeah yeah Wow safety
safety is huge okay and then I will also
want to mention this as we move on that
you had three years in Vienna as well
still this is still going on right for
you with the meeting on the commission
of non narcotic drugs yeah okay and then
how would that relation to the to the
cannabis as well well spring up at that
okay that was maybe yeah related to the
cannabis so there is a commission on
narcotic drugs that actually meets
annually and in 2009 they had a
political declaration that defines the
aims for the next ten years of the drug
policy worldwide what do we want to
reach and basically some of these aims
back then were still very clear we want
to have a drug-free world we want to
eradicate poppy fields in Afghanistan
and then also the cocaine plants in
Libya and Colombia but what was happened
was actually the opposite over these ten
years like this year in March the
ministerial segments the high-level
segment had to decide what's happened
and they don't really take stock of
these changes but there was a
reimprinting the on gas which was the
United Nations General Assembly special
session on on drugs and they also
analyzed what's happened over the years
and nothing has actually changed nothing
has decreased in some countries we have
better numbers now where we can better
locate who is using drugs and how many
people but the demand has not decreased
in none of the countries and importantly
for cannabis like the you
conventions actually say this is a
Schedule A drug so it's illegal and
there is no medical purpose and this is
of course changing now if the whole
science around medical value of some
forms of cannabis and some contaminants
some constitutions of cannabis that have
a medical benefit but that was again not
really discussed and then while the
united states have made has several
states that have legalized cannabis this
is nothing that the u.s. talks about at
this meeting you will see us still
follows that idea we want to have like a
drug-free world and they don't bring up
like intentionally their own experiences
with these legal markets so they abstain
from that and what was happening in
Canada was that Canada has legalized
cannabis federally that was a decision
made by the government and that was
discussed at this meeting too because
that actually moves beyond the
conventions and they were also
discussing about exclusion of Canada
what didn't happen but it will be very
exciting to focus on that meeting and
the whole international range when it
comes like cannabis is now the first
struck we discussed but maybe other
drugs may follow like countries may look
for ways how to regulate the drugs to
actually they reduce to harm and
increase public health and so that is
something we really have to focus on
yeah it's a public health issue
exactly and in this so there's a 10-year
that we're trying to look kind of like
views this as kind of like a sustainable
goal for our future and we kind of we
need better data on measuring we need
better practices on treating it like a
public health this is kind of what also
leads us into the global drug survey
stuff so this is this is oh you started
in 2000 I think 12 was only like 12,000
people or something exactly yeah yeah
and it's crazy because now seven years
later or six years later because it
ended lies that that there were a
hundred and twenty thousand people so an
order of magnitude increase in in
including myself I love
your I loved your survey I thought your
survey was very friendly
it was very promoting me to be honest
and I felt very comfortable submitting
answers to you because I want to figure
out I want to be a help I want to be
helpful I think that's what a lot of
people thought when they were when they
were doing this so teachers about global
drug survey and what has been going on
the last couple years of this so to make
the link from the United Nations back to
global drug survey it's very interesting
because like the United Nations Office
on Drugs and Crime see you know DC they
publish upcoming on June 26 The Verge
drug world track report like each year
they publish a birth drop report where
it takes together all the data from the
countries that is available to look at
drug markets and so on and they also
talk about the seizure data that this
data on how much of the drugs were
seized and depending on the political
goals of the countries these data change
and if they focus more or have a higher
budget and law enforcement of course the
numbers go up and that can be seen as a
success for many countries but it
doesn't tell you anything about how the
people in your country use the drugs and
what it does when you actually seize a
lot of drugs can also be dysfunctional
for for the communities because if you
like seized a lot of trucks then maybe
the drug becomes more expensive because
it's more risky for the dealer to
provide the drugs to the people who are
maybe addicted to the drugs and need the
drugs so these are all thoughts that are
need to be for in addition to just
looking at the numbers and then the
countries and the National Household
surveys they mainly look at how many
people have used a certain kind of drug
in the last year ever or like in the
last 30 days and these are good
indicators to look who is using in your
country and what we see with cannabis is
that of course these prevalence rates
are kind of increasing because the more
people hear about it the more likely
they are to try and the more legal and
accepted it becomes the less stigmatized
the more likely they are to report in
National Household Survey so we in the
global drug survey we are not really
interested in these numbers in how many
people use drugs but we want to know how
because we want to make an assumption
about the risk that is related to use
and if I'm talking about risk related
reviews many studies just like I said
they just take 12-month prevalence and
that's really not sufficient because
what you want to know is the amount of
use like how much of the drug do they
use you want to use to freak you want to
know the frequency of use how often do
these people use you also want to know
Polly drug use like whether they use
other substances concurrently and or in
combination with these drugs and you
want to know something about the most is
for youth because some people may
actually benefit from certain kinds of
drugs and use them as a sales medication
for whatever reason so there are many
components you want to understand to
actually be able to say whether a person
is using a drug very risky or not you
have to form a survey that that it
builds an emotional connection with the
person that's submitting it to feel like
in their in their country of course and
they're I mean they're like their social
fabric has to make it easy like think
you gave our example in Afghanistan
people were less likely to to submit but
that my dosage my frequency of use my
motives for use all these things are
there's a heart these are very hard to
to get people to want to talk about but
they're so important once you collect
this data to gain insight about the
country and about the the motives the
behaviors also that question that you
you reminded me of the question which
was that would you would you pay
additional money if the drugs were
sourced to you in a non-violent way yeah
in a way that didn't harm other people
in the
in the acquisition of the drugs and
people were saying yes like 25 percent
they were paid 25 percent more for the
acquisition of the drugs which is great
to hear as well because people are
they're kind they're they're more aware
of the process that we're yeah because
people can get harmed from the way I
think that's a very important point and
that also help turns back to how we
actually create new questions or new
models because last year Mexico and
Colombia really approached us and said
that there are big issues with violence
related to drug trafficking so they
wanted to do something like on the
political level and we were just
thinking about like let's ask our people
who actually use this cocaine would they
be ready to pay more if they would know
that this is like produced fair trade
and it's a very interesting survey
because that what do you see on this
slide is just a core research team Adem
lynnster cruises psychiatrist in the UK
who's funding the survey so it's not
funded by like a national organization
like the National Institute of Health
for example because it's really funded
by one person and that's why we are also
able to ask the questions we want to
like each year new questions and the
other to my collaborators Jason and
Monica in Australia means which render
now in the United States we work
together with a bunch of harm reduction
organizations researchers in the field
and people at the ground to actually
figure out what are the new trends and
topics where we don't have data at but
we don't have like a validate question
or like for the depression or anything
where we can go through and screen and
say oh this is the case so we are really
happy to bring up new topics and you see
the pizza picture and there last year
for the first time we asked the people
how long it takes to get pizza delivered
and among those people who are also
ordered cocaine to be delivered to their
house or to a point we asked them how
long this takes if it was delivered
within a day and we were seeing that in
cities like Zurich or like Amsterdam and
so on where a lot of the like drug
dealing is also connected to social
media user whatsapp and so on
communications via social media
there we were seeing that the cocaine
was delivered faster than Pizza
where's this that also like contributes
you understanding like the different
kinds of struck markets and scales about
other things we did were for example you
see a drinking like 30-minute delivery
in less than 30 minutes like there were
more people who could get cocaine were
in less than 30 minutes when compared to
ordering pizza and in which market its
in switz and in different bigger cities
like also in Germany or also in Germany
to probably some from the United States
but I didn't look at that whoa yeah
and these are of course questions we
come up with that are not very oh yeah
exactly these are those questions that
yeah yeah if you you can come up it's
cool that your team can form a question
that gives you such a unique insight
into the global drugs seeing that you
wouldn't have been able to access if you
didn't form this unique question that
got them that yeah yeah so your the
question design is actually a really
crucial component of this yeah so are
you guys already thinking about the
questions because to teach people
you-you-you take surveys in November and
December yes and then you end the survey
period so you can analyze the data for
the several month period like five six
months and then you release the findings
the key find the key findings yes as a
publication which is online on global
drug survey don't come that's global
drug survey calm you can find that a
link in the bio global drug survey 15
key findings like three weeks ago when I
was in Amsterdam for the top health
conference and we got a pretty big media
attention again across the countries
because they're keen to report on it and
each year we have new modules and as you
said right now we're preparing already
TTS 2020 which will be like collected in
November and December so if you're now
watching please take part in November in
December right say your calendar set a
reminder feather reminder I'm going to
submit again yeah are you Ron to submit
you go ahead and are laying back yeah
what is maybe special about this survey
also to maybe just mention it is that
people really trust us and we also
really want to help make turkey safer
for those people who decide to use drugs
but when I'm talking about drugs I'm
talking about both legal and illegal
drugs and like one-third who takes part
has never used an illegal drug and
cannabis is still I counted as an
illegal drug globally right so one-third
takes part and shares their experience
with alcohol tobacco use
moment pharmaceuticals exactly
pharmaceuticals and this year for
example we had we were collaborating
with different people in field of
psychedelic science and looking into
like giving people something some food
for thought where with the current
developments we asked them how likely
they would be if they were diagnosed
with depression or PTSD to actually seek
different kinds of treatments like talk
therapy antidepressants or treatments
with psychedelic drugs like psilocybin
and Alice tea because these drugs at
least for the recreational use we were
seeing that psilocybin was the safest
rock when we looked at emergency medical
treatment seeking compared to that and
that was a really important measure and
like people who take part
don't use illegal drugs can of course
also participate in modules like this
and for the upcoming survey in November
we will have one really specific module
on nightlife and substance use so again
people who go out and who go clubbing it
no matter whether you use legal or
illegal drugs and no drugs they can all
participate Wow
question you guys are yeah yeah GDS is
you have this really cool trajectory
that I'm seeing right now which is like
you continue to design powerful
questions build up more and more people
around the world that want to submit
answers for this global public health
understanding and the hash tag know your
drugs you know this type of thing you're
gonna build out a really cool I can see
this growing so you know millions of
people submitting to this every single
year and that yeah and taking and
researchers from around the world
wanting to query the
to find additional findings that a small
team maybe you grow your team maybe they
query data yeah yeah yeah we actually
really welcome participation or
collaborations with researchers
especially when they have for example
research funding want to look at a
certain kind of question that we already
addressed and we can maybe provide data
from multiple years so we're not looking
at the same sample each year but we can
still like look at trends for example in
darknet market used like we're the only
survey that actually has each year data
for different countries for different
participants but still like for similar
groups in the similar countries whether
they have used boats whether they have
ports trucks from the darknet for
themselves for someone else or whether
someone else bought for them and these
data again are also featured in the word
truck report because no one else
actually gets this data from the demand
side like from people who use trucks
they only have supply side like they're
studying the markets online and they
look at it also from a law enforcement
perspective but like the actual data who
is buying and whether these markets are
growing as a response to Prohibition or
other things is just visible from the
data we have in if this also shows to us
how fascinating it is that if the
government was to query you for your
drug use behaviors you'd be so much a
little more likely to be like hesitant I
don't want to give that like NSA my my
drug use behaviors but if it's like a
what appears to be like a private
benevolent research organization that's
about global health public health humans
are so much more willing to like answer
the questions and and yeah so that's
that's a very interesting dynamic that
is developing in our world well in an
ideal world like if you would be my
employer we would have a normal
discussion about my and your drug maybe
just my drug is million at the point of
employment because what you could do by
having more honest and transparent
conversations about drugs is actually
seeing if someone's use is changing over
time and then ask specifically why this
is changing and then be early for early
detection and most importantly early
into
when problematic substance use occurs
and with dad you could like get rid of
lots of lots of problems now because who
how often do we really ask each other
these questions like yeah how often are
you drinking why what are you the
incentives behind drinking because if
someone clears me and asks you know why
did you stop you know how often do you
drink and smoke cannabis and I'm like I
don't then why focus I want to focus on
what I'm building what I'm working on
Hawken do you psychedelics well maybe
several times a year I like to explore
what it does to the state of my of my
mind what I can creatively understand
connect to unity all these types of
things so but to actually have these
conversations in an open way with our
co-workers our family friends like
people online like we need more of open
dialogue around it and less taboo and so
this is huge for for doing that
promoting honest conversations about
drug use I love it I love it um will you
uh will you teach us you're you're good
we'll get we'll get to this in a quick
moment I want to know your take on this
it's so interesting that we should
decriminalize but we don't know how yet
to structure the legalization because
here we see Oakland decriminalized the
shrooms and other natural psychedelics
so it's like decriminalize but we don't
know how to structure legalization teach
us about what what that is right so this
year in Denver
satis ivan mushrooms have been
decriminalized and yesterday last night
of after 11 p.m.
my friends were gathering in oakland at
the city hall when they announced that
also oakland unanimously approves the
decriminalization of sacred plants
including psilocybin like the magic
mushrooms including i boca versus
ibogaine and even DMT which is like food
ayahuasca plan so these sacred plants
and peyote a San Pedro as you can see
they are obviously
growing in nature and they were once
also criminalized as part of the war on
drugs and people are now starting to
question this because why should we
criminalize the nature and like
different forms of psychedelic
substances have of course different
risks and it can be very overwhelming to
use any form of psychedelic substance
for the first time if you don't know how
so like when driving a car you should in
Tier you have some ideas about how to
use it and what measures to take that
you have people with you and so on so
this is excellent we said we don't
imagine if you never drove a car ever in
your life and you just started it oh
yeah I'll be sixty mile an hour on the
interstate too fast yeah so also if
close the truck sorry we provide some of
the checklists that you should go
through when you decide to use a drug
for like LSD for the first time so
that's something we think is very
important and yeah people can like with
the right guidance these plants are
relatively safe to use and has been used
for years and years like for thousands
of years also as part of rituals and the
thing is that in the Western culture
would take these plans of course a bit
out of their context and we want to
monetize them come at a time and of
course like with every other drug we
would like to see decommodification that
it's more about that gifting and like
you think about 30 men and ten
principles that brings it actually very
well together where it's really about
the community and about like looking at
these plans and seeing who's benefiting
from these trends in what kind of doses
they have to be used or should be used
and what it means and again it's not
legalized and it still can be
criminalized cycles obviously under the
federal law but it was just made the
lowest like interest for the for the
police to prosecute so they have more
important things to do yeah yeah murder
rape there's so much so many more worse
things to be doing than people that are
trying to connect to God or like unity
who are yet or integrate in heal trauma
right yeah yeah yeah okay so so
what would an ideal so yeah please
responsible use totally responsible use
cycle with with us psychedelic
psychotherapy all the fun types of yeah
responsibly uses here with with give us
idea of what it would look like for an
potential ideal legalization structure
have Union colleagues talked about what
that could look like well I mean for all
of these plants and other than Kennedy's
there are currently no models available
that have been tested or piloted or
anything so it's really different
difficult to think about like the legal
context importantly from the perspective
of the person who decides to use the
drug what is important is that people
who are looking into more kind of
self-medication things especially with
psychedelic plants it's important that
the experience is guided that you have
like integration prior and also after
using the substance therapeutically so
at the moment we have of course a lot of
studies and great work by maps like the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic science that has been shown
not only in the US but also in other
countries that it's possible that people
benefit from it and that symptoms that
are otherwise can't be treated with
medical interventions can be addressed
with these things and it's really
successful but of course not for
everyone
and that's important to know like even
with positive findings there we still
need to see who is actually benefiting
from it and who's not and the same is
true for the recreational market like
the good thing that psychedelic drugs is
that they are not really like addictive
looking at the physical level compared
to drugs like heroin or methamphetamine
or whatever but Phil they can of course
if you use it as a tool to either like
increase your well-being or your
performance like a topic we discussed
next yes it can be also creating like a
kind of psychological dependence that
you only think you're able to thrive
only with these products and of course
our human body is very good as it is if
it gets enough sleep well good nutrition
enough of sports and me
also enough of social interaction and
that's another thing to consider that is
not included in the debate yeah this is
a very cool perspective on on reality is
that if with the right amounts of with
them with a beautiful social fabric that
can actually do things like give people
the really powerful family structures
and and social structures and nutrition
sleep exercise would do we even need
these things like the use of smart drugs
on the rise that we need these cognitive
enhancers that we can connect to divine
feelings and potentials without adderall
and without nootropics potentially but
then some people say well we're
biologies too slow we need to we need to
enhance ourselves from the outside we
need to be more productive in the world
so what are your thoughts on the
cognitive enhancement self optimization
space because your your article in
nature news you had a paper that was was
referenced on fifteen countries using
drug enhancers just cool today yes yes
yeah it's funny because like the
journalist that is pictured here
actually approached me again this year
and asked for data about cognitive
enhancement in the survey and we didn't
include it again we had it in 2015 and
17 survey and not in the 19 anymore
because we tried to make the survey
always more user friendly so we take
less and less modules in there and only
ask where specific populations of
interests for it never the mind never
mind I was like looking at data from 15
countries in these three years and I was
like the US was we didn't look at
prevalence but of course that rates in
the samples and the US was highest like
from the beginning it was of course the
sample of people use drugs but they were
not much higher than like the general
population of students or the general
student population in the country
and it was interesting to see that the
different drugs differed between the
countries so as you said in the United
States for adderall I take Sam said to
mine which is really strong and this
like license
available for people who are treating
symptoms of ADHD or a DD with it it's
licensed this was the most common truck
and in other countries like in the UK
modafinil it's a medication for
narcolepsy or Ritalin in other European
countries most like prevalent and we
were seeing a gradual increase more in
other countries that were more
restrictive and has at the same time
more like pressure on the education
system so that was an interesting link
that we figured out in that paper and I
was featured in nature at the time yeah
the future of this field is be so nuts I
this also kind of speaks in depth about
what's happening in Silicon Valley
there's a lot of hype around micro
dosing I want maybe speak on that and
also how the research shows that
psilocybin is actually the safest drug
right yeah that was my link going from
the decriminalized nature to the
enhancement debate because psilocybin
when we looked at all the people who
used a certain drug like each year and
we looked at all who used alcohol all
use cannabis all who used Tyler siphon
and then looked in this group who was
actually showing up in the emergency
medical treatment seeking like last year
then this proportion was always lowest
for the psilocybin for people who use
psilocybin
we had each year about 10,000 people
that we questioned and so that was
really profound and new to ask for them
like that's a trend that comes again
every year and among those with the
highest like emergencies we see of
course heroin or synthetic cannabinoids
and like things that are more difficult
to those and also drugs that are more
and more contaminated with other
substances so that's another topic we
may come back later but when looking at
the enhancement debate and also micro
tossing we have data in the global drug
survey as well we see first studies
coming up looking at whether people
benefit or not but it's difficult again
to make these studies as long as the
drugs are illegal under federal law so
it
immensely costly to get the drugs and
you cannot just buy them on the streets
and see whether they are good so you
produce them in a laboratory but only
like some kinds of laboratories are
certified to actually produce it for
research purposes and we have a bunch of
research looking at the effects of like
psilocybin and LSD in healthy people
also coming from Switzerland from my
colleagues trailer leaf tea and that a
University of Basel and suruc today of
doing a good amount of work there but
for micro tossing we really know very
little and we hear it as a trend and
it's it's it's it's kind of trendy for
media they want to hear more about that
too but the only thing I can say what
we've seen in the global drug theory
among the people who have used the drugs
and who have tried micro dosing many of
them had only tried one or two times or
a few times and not so many of them
would report micro dosing on a regular
basis and so it's still yeah again like
with every other drug it's dependent on
the amount like you really just would
need a one in ten of like the drug and I
never actually tried it myself so I
can't even give you like the personal
experience story to that but I think
that of course there are people who may
have difficulties with focusing who can
benefit from it but overall again like
other factors in your lifestyle behavior
are probably more important than
significant in predicting your
performance and then there's um so
there's this oh there's this um what is
the the next the next asset we have is
an image from what we like dislike when
you enter into a festival what is it
called when you get the it's checked
what is a checking check-in process Rock
checking drug check-in yeah okay a drug
check-in okay yeah what's okay what's
happening with drug check-ins at like
music festivals at burning man's and all
these different what are drug check-ins
and also what's going on with and we'll
get to the next asset which kind of
shows kind of what the progress has been
with different countries and
okay right so also when we think about
nightlife festivals people who micro
those in Silicon Valley over ever we
people who take part in a global drug
survey we always talk about a really
privileged population and usually people
have a university degree or they're more
likely to be represented and seek these
services or take part in a survey and
the other people are maybe don't even
care for like what's in the drug or
don't have access to anything and so as
long as drugs are illegal one of the
main health risks is related to not
knowing what is in the drug that there
can be potentially like health harming
components into drugs and also that
there can be like a high dose of a
certain drug more than you actually want
to take like when you drink alcohol on
the label again you know exactly how
strong the alcohol is so you know that
appear has less it's less strong than
maybe a certain kind of wine and maybe
less strong than spirits and you can
make more informed decisions on how much
you want to drink too we also sometimes
ask the people in the survey how much
they need to get tipsy or to feel an
effect to get as drunk as they want to
be or to get more drunk as they want to
be so people can relate that based on
standard drinks really clearly it's not
the case with drugs yeah and
nevertheless certain many countries are
also community organizations have
realized that early on in the 90s when
there was a techno boom in Germany and
in Europe and also here like different
kinds of new communities existed and
then it suddenly became important to
know what's in the drug to actually make
it less harmful for those people who
decide to use drugs and the Netherlands
were actually the first to start with
the themes like a drug information
monitoring system run by the government
basically or directed by the government
and there the idea was also mainly to
monitor drug markets so it was not just
to help people use drugs more safely but
to know a bit more about what's in the
drugs and Spain and other countries
followed and also the United
it was in 1997 very early on with
tensive an organization that still
exists mm-hmm and the picture before was
from lightning in a bottle so they are
present at this festival and also at
Burning Man or other festivals but they
provide like the drug tests call it
tests is it Dean saved art artwork I
think yeah shout out because they're
doing the safe - testing well safe
testing is probably the wrong thing
because no treasure is ever safe and
it's also not safe because again they to
the collet Cola metric tests where they
can identify the drug and say that
whether the drug is there or not but
they don't have like mass spectrometry
methods or whatever available because
it's still under federal law illegal to
actually test drugs for people who want
to use them so they're they're not
allowed officially to do that and the
whole drug checking debate that now
comes to the US is related to harm
reduction context because the herring is
laced with fentanyl so they're at some
of the services they provide now more
than just color test or the first pilots
are coming but it's not for the majority
of people who use drugs at festivals or
in nightlife settings recreationally but
for the small most vulnerable population
which uses trucks and are addicted to
drugs right and the difference is also
like people who are addicted to drugs
and may not have the money to afford
drugs they are less likely to give away
their drugs whereas people were like
again well seated and privileged they
may be more likely to use services like
drug checking and importantly if we look
at the next graph there's yeah it looks
like yeah it looked the one right just
right before this round there's there's
a majority of these of like kind of like
some developed countries are moving
towards drug check-in processes this is
good this is something good if you look
at the publication you can also see
which methods they use we also have a
service appendix where you can look up
all the different services and again
more services are starting now but again
those who don't have like financial
means they are not available to actually
bring in met
that can both identify and purify the
substance and even then it's not totally
safe to use it but people can that can
make more informed decisions on how much
to use so if I'm in these countries I
can have there's there's an organization
that will come either a government or
private organization or potentially an
NGO that will come and be at the
festival that I will be at and I will
take my substance that I would like to
use it to festal and I can get it tested
right there on site by that and then of
course like you were describing some of
the methods are not absolutely fantastic
for this process and it's not quite
there fully like legally that this is
like incorporated like a legal process
it's still like mmhmm yeah okay okay so
we're moving in a direction of safer
drug use at least effective for those
people want to know what's in there and
what we've seen especially in European
countries was really an increase in for
example the purity of cocaine and then
people have undesirable experiences
because it's higher potency than
experienced than expected and the same
was true of MDMA like the substance in
the ecstasy pills and if we move to the
maybe next slide okay slowly we will see
that we had a campaign a mix Mac where
we said don't be tough start with ha
what does it do have to me don't be
stupid
just take don't don't take the whole I
love you don't take the house don't be
daft
and where does that word come from dust
Punk Oh Daft Punk no that's like a slang
it's more UK language I would say don't
be Duff do you know who Daft Punk is of
course that you're asking the wrong age
group yeah you would have to ask the
like 10 year olds if they know who Daft
Punk you yeah that would be okay yeah
yeah so this were you how do you know
who Daft Punk is your old don't worry
about me yeah so the pill was splitted
but nowadays in Europe you would even
add another split to take just a quarter
because we will see one of the peaks oh
cool oh yeah
down even a quarter go down even start
with a quarter and we also asking the
global drug sorry of course where the
people start with the test those when
they use a new pill from a new batch
because they can never be sure what's in
there yeah that's huge - yeah yeah and
so in America still like the enemy is
not as pure and the appeals are not
always as strong so there are huge
discrepancy and differences between the
pills so here it would it would be even
more important to know for people who
use recreationally but again because the
drugs are illegal these services are
still not provided because they don't
think that this would be something to be
supported but again also people in
America they use the drugs anyway even
if they don't know what's in there and
this is also such a such a critical
thing to get good at is understanding
that whether it's cannabis or he may or
whatever psilocybin LSD whatever it is
that starting with like a super small
dose and being patient is so critical
and then what we can do from that yeah
is we can actually learn that oh like
because there's like a little like
cannabis tic-tac that you can take now
that's only like 2 milligrams of
cannabis and you can take that and it
can be like super non psychoactive
whatsoever and it's just like tiny
little body like good feel and and like
soo so there's all of these different
dosages that are potential and it's so
much still to explore but sometimes
you're just given this massive Korova
bar that is like a thousand milligrams
or 500 milligrams right and you eat it
and then it's like you're blasted and
yeah so so chill out take smaller start
with half start with a quarter yeah yeah
yeah this is a very good at like slogan
for safety yeah right yes it's excellent
one
and what about the next interpret trends
inform about safer use and inspire
change yeah that was more like a summary
of this section it's fit to be around
screen Ron well yeah so that was more
like a summary of what we just like
talked about that it's really like what
is important to understand is really to
interpret the trends like from a science
perspective that's what we wanted to we
don't really we should not care so much
about how many people do it that's
important for like some government
numbers and to scale to see how big your
use is in the country but it doesn't
tell you anything about the problematic
use and again when looking at drug
markets it's really interesting to see
where people actually sourced it and
drugs from also when you have a legal
marker to see whether they actually buy
from the legal market or whether they're
per ears to buy from the legal market
shows such as high taxes for example
that exclude certain populations that
maybe are in need of good information as
well and again like the information
share it's like with everyone we can
find and then maybe inspire change like
by projects like all the drug survey and
other discussions we have by the
discussion today we may be able to
inspire change a behavior change for
some people but we usually don't see
that change happening from just
prohibiting substances and just saying
that drugs are bad and there's there's a
lot more with with like just in general
understanding which factors drive
problematic use I think that's super
important also highlighting relevance of
social support dignity worthiness
inclusion these are things that are also
really important in what you guys are
going to be building developing out this
the next um the next asset that actually
this actually kind of speaks to some of
the social support yes it teaches about
that yeah that's like a brainstorming
slide it's about as I said inspiring
people and that we can do by connecting
people and on the upper side you see the
high dose ecstasy pill that was a pill
that was tested last month in
Switzerland like the different projects
countries also have different rules on
whether they put it online or not but
all the findings in Switzerland who are
higher than what we expect so those 120
milligrams per pill would be like the
dose that that can be recommended or
that is the highest dose we would
recommend and everything above it's
gonna be like yellow or above like this
is 146 this is 246 and how much 20 would
be the recommended dose for I can double
the recommend yes exactly that's why
that's happening exactly and I found it
funny to say to use this for connecting
people because you see Donald Trump on
the pill so the pill is actually in
Europe but with the logo from Donald
Trump so there is a connection between
us yes in Europe and the United States
and yeah these informations are of
course important for people if they want
to make a more informed decision they
would not like with a food ple
especially for people used to drug for
the first time it's way too much and
again they use the drug anyway and
what's also happening when we look at
nightlife in San Francisco we had the
night of ideas and you see there Steven
Roscoe from Burning Man
who is also coordinating all the
regional events and they were talking
about like how to actually improve the
life in the city and how to bring
communities closer together and
especially when we talk about substances
you want to talk about communities and
we want to talk about how we bring the
information out there to people yes and
another interesting thing in San
Francisco is San Francisco is one of the
nine cities that now may be able to
serve alcohol not just till 2:00 a.m.
but will 4:00 a.m. that was a bill
brought in for the third time by Scott
winner here in San Francisco and that
was something that struck me because in
Europe I never had to think about lost
coal we don't have that and I don't
I also compared to substance use
patterns across like European big cities
and United States but there is not no
difference so people are using they
don't changing their substance use
behavior just because there can be
served to two hours more and here the
people were really like artists cause
lots of violence and
be harmful but what it means for me is
that people don't have to go to the club
at 12 and put in a lot of alcohol either
before or in these two hours but they
can like plan for a longer period of
time and another thing is that by
actually ending making a last call and
having after hours happening you make it
more likely that people actually change
to illegal substances of course do you
know when they're gonna keep the bars
open till 4:00 do you have any idea I
think they have half the bill but I'm
not sure it can look that up online for
sure and I I just brought in another
example of a Detroit Berlin connection
like a new project it's a small scale
project they have only two thousand
followers on like Facebook but it's one
of the projects where we also discussed
about this 24 hours night life that can
actually make a city big and not just
like the way we think of New Orleans to
go and drink in the streets but to think
of a 24-hour City as like something with
like experience in nightlife where you
provide something for your community but
increasing the quality of what you
provide you also decrease the risk of
people just going there to get wasted
because you actually provide something
with content just Europe we have new net
which is enjoying a safer nightlife so
that the community across different
countries working together to actually
make that happen I love the phrase about
the content as well that if the contents
there it's not just about oh there's
nothing else to do let's go drink but
rather it's like there's fun things to
do there's maybe art there's maybe music
there's maybe science there's gonna be
cool history things to explore and learn
while you do engage with maybe some
substances and social friends and all
this type of stuff this [ __ ] scariest
[ __ ] right here that is so scary that
that that that type of stuff needs to
become more transparent because it can
cause people to go oh just is so short
and just like you're off and to you it's
unsafe alright that's the thing okay and
then on science communication you're
just giving us the example of which is
the next slide Ronnie that
that like you were giving us example
like there's more and more times that
you are now visiting with Sacramento
trying to push for smart legislature
that helps us with safety and
evidence-based drug policy so teach us
about what's happening in the space and
and also like like science we talked
about the very beginning science is such
an important thing to put forth and not
like necessarily politicize immediately
but keep more like a foundation of
objective truth and then move forward
and figure out the policy yeah teachers
about how you perceive that yeah so I I
never was so much interested in like
politics when I grew up like I never
joined the party or anything I work 50
United Nations Office on Drugs and Crime
and cut into a little bit of the
political context that we also may
discuss on the next slide again but when
coming to the United States I really
realized that there are a lot of NGOs
that are advocating for certain policies
either for or against cannabis very
clearly so there is the industry but
there are also interest groups and the
same is true like for for many of the
things and what we never actually
learned was how to communicate science
to policy makers and it's also
oftentimes not really hurt because the
ideology and the people who vote for you
actually direct what you gonna vote in
the assembly or in the Senate or
wherever you are elected to but at the
same time everyone wants to hear more
about science and when we look at drug
policy issues it becomes more and more
evident that we also should really look
back and see what else maybe not just
the u.s. but other countries Don what is
the experience what has works what has
not worked and what were the indicators
of failure because not every project
needs actually to do the same mistakes
again yeah easier said than done and now
it's become even more of a wisdom race
with AI and synthetic biology neuro
technology always pressing fields that
the oops
yeah is not okay anymore so science
needs to really get into policy right
yeah yeah
and like let's say until the last few
years there was absolutely no incentive
for a researcher other than publishing
in a scientific journal to actually make
an effort to also talk about the
research elsewhere I mean of course it
can help your reputation but it's
nothing that is incentivized at all in
the scientific community and that starts
to change now as well as or slow slowly
by slowly and by joining the UCSF
science policy group last year I can
really I could really see how we can
make these connections also not just
with the community that is affected by
the policies but actually to the policy
makers themselves and I think it's not
on us the researchers to actually make
those voices heard there must be other
channels as well but for the most part
people can speak up in the city hall at
a public hearing but other than that
they are not really like their
perspective is really not seen so it's
again just about political context and
less about the people and yeah when I
started to volunteer with the Project
Homeless Connect I had the opportunity
to meet Gavin Newsome that was last year
he's now the governor and like a really
influential person and also visiting the
Sacramento and the DC Capitol for in the
focus EJ as part of science policy group
or one of the professional societies was
really eye-opening for me to see like
how interested the staff of these
offices or the people themselves are in
having the information and to actually
provide the information and break it
down and then present it what they need
that's that's a big task but I think
it's it's on us especially the young
researchers who still have time and who
are engaged to actually reach out and
see what are the pending issues also of
climate change and so on to bring in the
experts and it's it's not on me to bring
it all expertise but I can also refer
people to experts in that field and to
actually make these connections that we
have more policy that is driven by
science and less by political will yes
amen
hell yes a lot of ground says and then
the next slide is an example of this so
supervised consumption facilities but in
the in San Francisco we're looking to
pass from Sacramento the overdose
prevention program right so yeah it's
about this yeah so in us basically
you've seen Gavin Newsom on the other
side and he's now the governor and the
last Governor Jerry Brown he has vetoed
the bill on supervised consumption
facilities for San Francisco on his last
day of action so that was really
unexpected because it has program like
gone through the whole process and
people have debated it and thought it
was worth installing and in a supervised
consumption facility is actually a place
where people can use their drugs that
are currently legal under federal law in
a safe space without being prosecuted
for their drug use and why we need that
is we only like need that as long as we
have people who were living on the
streets like people were experiencing
homelessness and they have no like room
where they can go or they don't have a
place to go and even again like if
people live isolated or on their own in
a small apartment or maybe subsidized or
whatever then equally it would be very
important to actually have a place where
they can use the drugs in a safe space
without being at risk as they're still
at risk of overdose but they have
someone around that could react
immediately to actually prevent deaths
and also prevents other negative
consequences from drug use we think this
is a step in the direction of safety and
in the direction of healing and to
provide supervised consumption
facilities and the overdose prevention
programs these are like steps in the
direction of safety and healing right
and these are steps that have been taken
by many countries like not by many bills
like 11 or 12 countries or now so a lot
yeah
have them like officially legalized in
in the United States as of today there
is no like legal facility in San
Francisco there is an underground
facility working that makes huge
progress and helped so many people so
it's really important but that Oliver is
like on the ground work so nothing is
actually known about it and the first
data was presented at the harm-reduction
conference in porto this year so in
Switzerland totally different scenario
you may not believe but we also have had
like like an open drug scene and
problematic heroin use for a bigger part
of the population so it was growing and
we had it especially in Zurich with
needle Park and in Bern where people
were traveling from over all over
Switzerland to these places to actually
use drugs and stayed there and started
selling drugs like it is to actually
afford to drug use but it's more like a
revolutionary aspect thing and not so
much driven by social inequalities like
as you have it here
nevertheless people also were of course
against drug use and they try to shut
down the needle park in Zurich like
repression law enforcement they shut it
down but then what happened was that
people just moved somewhere else so they
moved to a closed train station and just
the harm continued and people were just
getting into these lives and it was
still an open street scene and by
enforcing the law more there again it
went back to the city so the politics
had to take actions and that was the
point first it was also like voted
against but at a certain point it was
not just the needle exchange and the
substitution treatment Ike for Oprah you
sir that came but also supervised
consumption facilities so for the first
time in 1986 obviously so that's more
than 20 years more than 30 years ago
where the first one opened and in the
90s we had this again in Zurich and so
the Zurich site they are looking now
back to an experience of like 20 years
more than 20 years and we had four sites
and one of the sites has closed last
year because there is no more demand
yeah
that is Wow that's one of the point and
the graph here is just showing about the
age the yellow one are the age 21 till
30 who used this facility so dad went
down yes the whole context has changed
so people understood like harrion is a
user drug so no yet
young people would start engaging with
the truck even if they're unhappy or
whatever they would use probably other
drugs but not the herring and of course
they don't inject until the population
that is like 50 160 has gotten older so
people do not necessarily die from drugs
and even injecting drug use anymore but
they get older and that face like we're
facing now new challenges on what does
it mean for like senior homes and people
who are carrying a healthcare facility
is there for these people and another
important finding is that at the I was
visiting two of the treat safe
supervised consumption facilities in
Zurich in March and they were lining up
to getting the inhalation in the smoking
rooms but the people who got went to the
injection rooms were I could count them
on one hand so less and less people
injected rock but they found other ways
that are more safe you have less like
incidents like with your health and
absences so they found different ways to
actually use the drugs no the deaths
ever the mirror in none of the overdose
prevention sites or supervised
consumption side so that's one of the
main selling points right now because
you have obviously overdose deaths in in
in in America but that never happened
and you can easily reverse them in in in
Switzerland you mostly do that with oxy
oxygen just immediate action and here if
you have two fentanyl also like people
carry naloxone with them that can
actually be reversed over those really
important yeah we we can't ignore and
think that's gonna be a better solution
than actually dedicating resources and
attention towards the healing process
right yeah and maybe one last note on
that yeah downside is on the last
sentence of the flight
there was one paper that is really
important that has analyzed the whole
harm reduction system in Switzerland
looking at the HIV and Hep C outcomes
and they were actually looking if the
harm reduction stuff would have been
implemented three years earlier could
have prevented more than three thousand
HIV knew in
and more than one and a half thousand
eight steps just two years earlier and
that's like the whole umbrella of harm
reduction offers including supervised
consumption facilities and this is just
like food for thought like what can we
do today and how much politics do we
need to actually start implementing
these things of course we want the
cities to agree the neighborhood to
agree we need to talk to everyone when
you need to bring everyone on the table
but also what we need to do with the
crisis is happening action taken out so
that's the that some people's parents or
sisters or brothers or kids that are
passing because of our not
implementation of science-based evidence
so yeah yeah and Cho and Hari said it
really nicely like the country of
addiction is not sobriety but connection
yes again yeah not all of us would
probably fail with the drugs but those
who are alone maybe then it's a first
order issue of our social fabric and our
family values not scaling over time
promoting self dealing rather than
inclusive fitness and maybe that's a
good rap not the very last slide trust
time transparency walk us through these
yeah when we zoom in we also see these
three important points and I would say
like what we really need is trust like
in these communities that we want to
work with that we want to bring a change
like for them we cannot decide for them
we want to really know what the issues
are and of course it needs time like
time to either look at the
decriminalization outcomes or the
implications of legalization like
everything that we bring in maybe as a
pilot project or as a federal change
needs time to grow and there are
different measures and outcomes we can
measure so that's really important and
what we want like from all the sizes
actually the people are transparent
about both the risks and the benefits of
either certain drugs or certain
treatments that are available and
importantly like for the current
dialogues around drug policies also by
for example scaling up affordable
housing and scaling up substance use
treatment for many people who are
affected there is still this big gap
that they are not really
used in our society so they have no one
who says Alan great job tonight with
this discussion great inputs whatever no
one tells them that but when I see on
the street when I talk to these people
is that they have a lot of resources so
we need to think about much more broader
about like how to gain their trust but
also how to actually create some
opportunities for them to co-create
programs or actually spaces where they
can become creative and do something
that actually brings meaning meaning in
life yeah yeah and this the the that can
potentially be integrated with the with
the new programs that are implemented is
that some sort of like a co-creation of
meaning something that that it can be
worked on actually when we talk to
people out back on Stevenson Street here
between marketing between 6th and 7th on
Stevenson right by Market Street it's so
frequent that people say I'm a
philosopher I'm an artist or I'm a
musician I want some of my music is on
soundcloud these are like actually
frequent things that you hear from
people so it's not like that there's
there is there's there's Drive within to
make stuff it's like where is the
co-creative addition and so yeah we can
all help by building the fabric to help
with that process ignoring it's not
gonna do anything it's gonna make it
worse even more so it's gonna make it
worse a public health issue rather than
focusing more on a criminal justice side
of things and just like you give me
examples before the show started about
how people are like like in the
Philippines there's that it get death
penalty for for drug use yeah that's a
horrible it's word yeah yeah I mean
these are issues you're facing and we
see also that the divide is getting
bigger and bigger between like nations
that really want to become more
innovative or focus on public health
approach Canada is also going into a
direction
u.s. is watching a bit but on the other
side we have other countries where the
issues are just as big as here or bigger
and
the population is dissatisfied and the
measures that they take is actually to
criminalize people even more and up to
the death penalty where it really also
is at the intersection with human rights
and there it's it's big on the like
political discussions at the global
level but still the whole UN is not
really stepping in and like there is a
lot of freedom for these policies to
happen and again many activists and
people who address it but there is no
pressure or no incentive for them to
change their policy because actually
this is a policy that is accepted and
for us I think it just makes us think
more and more about in which society we
want to live in what we want to do about
like substances and everything that it's
usually more the societal problems and
not the drugs that are so bad that are
driving people into the problems that
they have so we need to maybe think
about how to change it something at the
system level and be more accepting also
towards these people who for whatever
reason have decided to use drugs or
can't decide whether they have user or
not anymore
so there you Tommy don't use the word
addict yes you said people with a drug
addiction is what you said and actually
I counter I also mentioned yet people
with the tech addiction or people with
the sugar addiction
instead of addict yeah life is all about
addiction we are addicted to different
things
without addiction we're mindless zombies
well the thoughts thoughts on that I
would just say you have another foot no
I think those is what makes the poison
and I believe strongly in the fact that
there is kind of responsible drug use
like no matter whether legal illegal
drugs tech or whatever whatever diction
it is when it is addiction it is
actually pathological it means that you
can't control it any more and the human
brain is actually made to control things
like our like frontal cortex like all
the executive functioning we are here to
actually if it's not a simulation we are
here to actually make things work and to
control things to take control over our
lives and we may be able to give out
give up control for certain experiences
very like purposefully but we don't want
to give up to control and all the health
otherwise so there it's about how we
create like a society and also system
that is actually protective of these
human values and treats every person
with dignity and respect yes yes and
this leads us to the last two questions
do you think we're in a simulation good
question I hope not because I mean
otherwise everything that we just went
through and everything that I was
working through over the past years
would be something that someone made me
think of and maybe a solution to a
problem but if it's a solution to the
problem which would mean that other
people in who are part of the simulation
are gonna be happier and healthier me
then I'm fine with that solution as long
as the science and evidence wins and
then last question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
hmm the most beautiful thing in the
world well for me I think it's this
thing called serendipity like all these
moments that happen unexpectedly all
these connections we make with people
things that bring other things together
that help us make sense of things and
again if we're in a simulation
then we're probably highly rewarded in
our dopamine is crazily
up if we make these connections but
that's like experiences these moments of
serendipity and getting inspired day by
day that's what makes me happy yeah yeah
the more we head towards our North Star
and we're aligned with that the more it
seems like they're certain to pitous
things that are happening there's so
much good stuff there
Lursa has been such a fantastic show I
feel I feel super enlightened thank you
for coming on and teaching us
evidence-based drug policy thank you so
much for having thank you thank you huge
thank you huge thank you and also I'd
love for others thank you for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you tuning in
listening watching we would really
appreciate it we would love to have you
talk more about evidence-based drug
policy with your friends your co-workers
family people online on social media get
talking more about this also get ready
set your calendar reminders for the
global drug survey November 1st is yeah
or even if it earlier you're even a
little bit earlier so set those calendar
reminders make sure to tell your friends
about that and get engaged with it and
also check out the rest of Lewis's links
below as well and also the also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations around the world that you
believe in support organizations like
simulation help us continue growing and
and prospering as well huge shout out to
Ron August for producing and directing
thank you very much Ron and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]